all righty now it is time for you want a
victory lap you got one seriously this
was the best week ever you had
everything Trump crushes impeachment
Nancy throws a fit the democrats implode
all that's missing is an invasion of
space creatures that tastes just like
Cinnabons
but look like Ryan Seacrest it's
beautiful
as in pizza holics self-destruct Trump
keeps going he doesn't have the wind at
his back he's got a category 5 hurricane
a million Eric swells all farting at the
same time the president use taxpayer
dollars to ask the Ukrainians to help
them cheat in election
[Music]
holy we would do that but it's like a
second Christmas - Gramps killing that
drifter which we had to bury in the
woods but that's another story
and you can measure the joy in the
misery of those who rooted against you
look at these winners at the State of
the Union in the face of so much good
news about lots of stuff they appeared
his joy lists as a boarded up liquor
store would it kill them to stand up and
applaud once no they're so bitter they
poop grapefruits and there's Nancy
ripping up the speech like it was her
bar tab turned out she actually needed
it pre ripped so she could actually pull
it off makes me wonder who actually cuts
up her food
[Applause]
but she got the attention she wanted but
so did Trump I didn't really realize how
great this speech was until I saw her
pathetic frustration and all that
shuffling the shuffling that shuffling
she's like the world's worst blackjack
dealer she was a mess because she knew
where this was going
we went through hell unfairly did
nothing wrong did nothing wrong I've
done things wrong in my life I will
admit not purposely but I've done things
wrong but this is what the end result is
you saw coming I saw it coming but the
media and the Dems faked it because it
fed their base and their bottom line
watching them think Trump was going to
be impeached it's like watching Tom
Arnold think he might have a career
comeback it ain't happening and when it
all fell apart so did they then Trump
did his presser it was a doozy
but hey this is politics this is
politics
and we were treated unbelievably
unfairly and you have to understand we
first went through Russia Russia Russia
it was all
piss we have to bleep that but anyway he
hit everyone including Steve Scalise
remember he got whacked
he got wet he got whacked my Steve right
I went to the hospital with our great
first lady that night right honey and we
saw a man that was not gonna make it
he was not gonna make it he was the
doctor and I told him his wife I said
she loves you why do you say that
because she was devastated a lot of
wives wouldn't give a damn
hey Steve Scalise I actually honestly
think you're better-looking now Steve
Scalise I actually honestly I think
you're better-looking now you're more
handsome ugly you weren't that good
looking you look good now that's amazing
but hey what about Bobby Richardson
Bobby Richardson would field the ball if
it's hit the first place he'll throw it
to the first baseman he had unbelievable
range this was not Steve Scalise Steve
had no range Steve Scalise what about
Christopher steel he should have sued
him - I should have sued him - but when
you're president people don't like suing
I want to thank my legal team by the way
not for that advice but for God
Trump is a loathsome human being isn't
he God Trump is a loathsome human being
isn't it these are the people looking at
me I'm really not a bad person
talk about fun but did the media feel
that way what do you think vindictive at
times profane angry rambling response to
his impeachment acquittal it was full of
revenge it was mean-spirited it was
poisonous the first time the word BS and
he didn't abbreviate it was used in the
East Room in a formal presidential
address it was dark because he's made
clear that his mind is dark this is
somebody in deep psychological distress
right now once again the shrinks come
out to play
but these morons couldn't diagnose
halitosis which they probably have much
less mental illness but hey if the media
were in the medical profession all of
their patients would be wearing toe tags
so why is it so bad for them well the
facts are killing them a new poll finds
that ninety percent of Americans are
satisfied with their personal life the
approval numbers for the Republican
Party or its best in years Trump's
numbers jumped during impeachment as new
job numbers in wages beat expectations
all this prosperity and happiness what
do the Dems have to offer division
victimhood cancel culture identity
politics class warfare anger no wonder
the Democratic Party's less popular than
frying bacon in the nude learned after
that this is the first time they faced
any real competition in the street
fighting Department I mean can you
remember the last time Trump rolled over
well unless it's over someone in a world
of mitts he's a boxing glove he punches
back a lot and it can be exhausting for
everyone included Republicans who aren't
used to it but it's also hilarious after
his acquittal Trump tweets memes that
trigger everyone from Bette Midler to
Gavin Newsom
and they deserve it but so do we we
deserve to see them freak out
it's our reward for months of hysteria
[Applause]
but you know there's something else to
be thrilled about for for the median the
Dems politics was always really personal
politics spilled into sports education
entertainment it polluted everything but
Trump has somehow reversed the current
he's brought real life into politics
jokes insults honest-to-god laughs true
it's a New York kind of life across
between a construction boss and a cab
driver but still it's great because it
drives the establishment bonkers so is
it over
hardly the hate is deep and it's an
emotional investment too heavy to
discard so we'll go through impeachment
again millions of dollars months of
attention fulfilling a phony exercise
with the media strongly behind it really
impeachment is a fantasy sports league
for losers but as they get worse
Trump seems to get better because
impeachment is his vitamin you keep
making them he'll keep taking them
[Applause]
tonight yes she's got gall in a southern
drawl Fox Business Network anchor
Dagan McDowell
he's written more scripts than a doctor
at the ER TV writer/producer Rob long
she's the face of a generation excuse me
Jen she's the face of gin hostess and
chili count on Fox Nation cat tip these
days ripped as president Trump scripts
my massive sidekick and host an upset
[ __ ] pirate
diggin diggin diggin did you feel pity
for the Dems this week he had a great
week they had a terrible one no pity but
when it comes to a loser I prefer a sore
loser beat them they have a total
meltdown it helps you savor the victory
it puts an exclamation point on it and
say we were denied that Hillary
Clinton's meltdown cuz she hid after she
lost a daughter wait we've been waiting
for over three years yes to watch
well what Nancy Pelosi did at the State
of the Union address she was she
practically had a Twitter in her fight
shoe she was biting the inside of her
mouth and then whammo
she just completely lost it and it just
drove home the victory yeah you know Rob
I keep I cannot but notice that the
response to Trump never changes it's
like oh my god he said this I can't
believe he said BS it's like they live
in a world where they never hear these
things and coming from a president how
awfully it's been three or four years
move on well also I mean look the guy's
funny yeah a friend of mine and writes
for one of those late-night comedy shows
and he's sort of a trump supporter and
he they're all watching all the writers
are watching Trump give one of those
speeches and trans make a bunch of jokes
and he transfers fellow comedy writers
and say I mean okay come on the guy's
funny yeah ya know is now I mean you
don't have to like him to think he's
funny
I mean and I think that is ultimately is
the problem for the Democrats is that
you have a bunch of people who don't
like him I mean I don't like him yeah
but I mean I like 3% unemployment yes
like 200,000 and new jobs yeah I mean I
like that I like I like all the things
he said in the State of the Union which
are genuine success is that any
president has a right to claim yeah and
he did it and they just what do they
have they have well things are good but
we're mad as hell about it yeah I mean
you realize what you don't have you
don't have to like his words and like
his deeds it's it's but saying this
forever that in fact there might be a
correlation between his obnoxiousness
and the success because anybody thought
about that Americans didn't hire him to
be their friend
no they hired him do the job yes and he
he did his like four year review
performance review
Tuesday night and I'm pretty good yeah I
mean I can't get a raise but also I'm
the guy who said it wasn't gonna work it
kills me to say it's true
I was wrong hey you cat the weird thing
about it too is that he was a an
achiever on the Republican side but he
was a pretty good liberal president some
of the things he was talking about what
things that Democrats should have been
applauding some of them transcended
politics period right so everybody has
to agree that Donald Trump has said and
done many things that anyone else it
would have ended their political career
a long time ago and the Democrats don't
get it
they're running around be like what how
is this possible what is this sorcery
and I'm like I don't know about sorcery
but I do know that a lot of it has to do
with you guys yes I think a perfect
example is the way they acted at the
State of the Union it wasn't just the
paper ripping it was when he's talking
about those things that do transcend
politics like low unemployment like Oh
honoring a veteran lawmakers are
standing up and cheering and they're
sitting Alec yeah risked your life for
my freedom
why Republicans have such an easy time
saying well if you oppose and it's just
because of Trump derangement syndrome
right because even if you do have a
legitimate concern or a complaint about
him or his presidency responses people
aren't going to take us seriously
because you've already proven you don't
need a reason right to be complaining
and pissed off no that's an excellent
point
Tyrus what do you make of the week well
let's focus on the positive yeah well
the Democrats because I was sick all
week mm-hmm so I watched a lot of TV and
you have to wait a long time to get to
the good stuff so I watched a lot of
coverage of the impeachment trial and I
watched a lot of the Iowa caucus stuff
yeah and I remember watching in the
beginning when they were trying to form
lines mm-hmm like who what group whose
viable who's not viable I'm headed old
and the nice old elderly lady who
couldn't count the 127 people in the
room
yeah and lined them up was in charge of
an app and I remember saying I know it's
just the cough medicine but she's gonna
screw this up hey literally I was like
no there-there have an app yes and
whenever you have glasses with a chain
on the end of it you are not supposed to
be the person to charge of a new app get
the library so her account and literally
and like I saw one person moving they
went from Biden to Warren and she was
like nope nope we got to start over like
and then then the best thing ever
yeah was an even older guy comes over to
help her a lot to suck don't know I
think it's 17 I think it's 24 and I'm
like they're going to mess this up yeah
like all of a sudden I was tuned in I
had three TVs going cuz I didn't want to
miss anything
and at one point I fell asleep in my
chair like this Oh Dave but still messed
it up
they couldn't count anything now what
they need to do what is get a big tent
and put it on from the camera at CNN be
like under construction
Democrats 2020 for new things coming yes
see you then take up I take up all right